Speaker 1: But Steve Bannon has more problems
than just Mitch McConnell because Roger Stone,
Steve Bannon's longtime ally turned foe.
Has now once again gone after Steve Bannon.
This past week, Roger Stone attempted to throw
Steve Bannon under the bus with regards to the
Jan. six insurrection by suggesting via his
Telegram account that Steve Bannon may have been
the one. That caused the Capitol riot. Here's
what he said. It is highly likely that Steve
Bannon really gave the order to breach the Capitol
and maneuvered patriots into dangerous positions.
A neophyte, Steve Bannon, was
willing to try crazy things like this
to curry favor with Trump, who had a no
interest. That's so he wrote it in Bannon's B.S..
So more Republican infighting now, this is an
interesting accusation from Roger Stone, who,
of course, was thrown under the bus by Steve
Bannon himself during Stone's criminal trial.
Bannon testified against him. So Stone
has had some bad blood against Bannon
ever since that happened. But of course,
Donald Trump gave him his presidential pardon.
So these two weirdos, I guess, are fighting over
who gets to be Donald Trump's right hand man.
Is it going to be Roger Stone or
is it going to be Steve Bannon?
Well, Roger Stone is not going to pull any
punches here. He is actually trying to say that
Steve Bannon is the one who incited the Capitol
riot. Now that's a strong accusation, right?
Now, Roger, if you've got evidence to back
this up, please do come forward with it.
I know you and your your little text there,
you suggested it. You didn't say you knew what
happened, you just said this may be a thing. Dig
a little deeper button. We're counting on you,
if you can take down Steve Bannon,
one by God, take down Steve Bannon.
Do it. Don't just sit there with wild
accusations. You can't get away with that.
You can't make these suggestions and then just
let that be it. No, man. If you've got something
now. Put it this way, as the airports say,
if you see something, say something. So I'm
putting that on you. Roger Stone, if you got
any evidence at all to suggest that Steve Bannon
may have been involved in planning the Capitol
riot in inciting the Capitol riot and calling
the people to stormed the Capitol, please come
forward, hand it over. Then that committee,
and maybe for once in your
life, you could be a hero
not just to the Republican dirty tricksters,
but maybe to the American public as well.
See, I'm just trying to appeal to your human side
if you have one. Heaven only knows if you do,
but yeah, I'm all with you. If you want to
take down Bannon, just putting it out there